♪
>> Dagen: PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS
AMERICA NEEDS HIS AGENDA BUT
DEMOCRATS CAN'T EVEN AGREE ON
IT.
NANCY PELOSI STRUGGLING ONCE
AGAIN TO GET HER PARTY ON BOARD.
SHE SAYS SHE HOPES TO PASS
INFRASTRUCTURE TODAY, AND THAT'S
EVEN AFTER BIDEN BEGGED
DEMOCRATS TO DO IT.
>> I'M ASKING EVERY HOUSE
NUMBER, MEMBER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, TO VOTE YES ON
BOTH OF THESE BILLS RIGHT NOW.
SEND THE INFRASTRUCTURE BUILT ON
MY DESK.
TEN THEY BUILD BACK BETTER BILL
TO THE SENATE.
>> Dagen: LIBERALS ARE RAMPING
UP THE INTIMIDATION TACTICS ON
THOSE WHO WANT TO PUMP THE
BRAKES, LIKE JOE MANCHIN.
>> WHY WON'T YOU FIGHT FOR ME?
>> JOE MANCHIN, IS IT WORTH IT?
IS THE MONEY WORTH IT?
IS THE MONEY THAT IMPORTANT,
JOE MANCHIN?
IS IT MORE IMPORTANT THAN MY
LIFE, JOE MANCHIN?
IS IT MORE IMPORTANT THAN YOUR
KIDS LIFE?
>> [CHANTING]
>> Dagen: MANCHIN IS DRIVING A
MASERATI AND LIVING ON A BOAT.
WHY AIN'T HE A REPUBLICAN?
JUST GET ON WITH THAT ALREADY.
>> Jesse: COME ON OVER, JOE.
THE DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP IS VERY
OLD AND THE OLDER YOU GET THE
MORE STUBBORN YOU GET.
YOU'RE LAUGHING BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT EVEN 30.
JOE BIDEN IS SO OLD, HE PROPOSED
TO HIS WIFE EIGHT TIMES BEFORE
SHE SAID YES.
NANCY IS 81.
IF YOU EVER MET IN 81-YEAR-OLD
WHO CHANGE THEIR MIND ABOUT
ANYTHING?
MANCHIN IS OLD TOO.
HE IS SITTING IN THAT MASERATI.
YOU CAN SEE HIS BLOOD WAS
BOILING.
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE HIM GO ON
THE OTHER DIRECTION.
PISTOL PETE PROBABLY WOULD'VE
PUT THE PEDAL TO THE METAL AND
JUST SQUASHED IT.
HE SHOWED SOME SELF-RESTRAINT.
HERE'S THE OF THE THING WITH
MANCHIN.
MANCHIN HAS MONEY ON THE LINE IN
WEST VIRGINIA.
HIS ENTIRE PORTFOLIO IS COLD.
HE'S GOT MILLIONS IN COAL.
DO YOU THINK JOE MANCHIN IS
GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
GREEN NEW DEAL?
IT'S GOING TO DESTROY HIS ENTIRE
BANK ACCOUNT, NOT TO MENTION THE
ENTIRE BANK ACCOUNT IN
WEST VIRGINIA.
THERE IS NO WAY HE IS PUTTING A
YES VOTE ON THIS.
NANCY PELOSI IS GOING TO RETIRE
PROBABLY IN 2022 WHEN THEY LOSE
THE HOUSE.
SO THE GAVEL IS TOAST IN NINE
MONTHS OR WHATEVER.
SHE KNOWS THIS.
SHE'S GOING TO EUROPE NEXT WEEK.
SHE'S GOING TO JAM THIS THROUGH.
DO YOU REMEMBER HOW THEY DID
OBAMACARE?
THE CORN HUSKER KICKBACK, THE
LOUISIANA PURCHASE?
THEY JUST STARTED DRIVING
CONGRESSMEN AND SENATORS.
BRIBING THESE HOLDOUTS WITH
PHARMA MONEY.
THEY DO THIS SALT TAFFY BRIBE.
THESE NEW ENGLAND CONGRESSMEN.
THAT'S ALL THAT'S HAPPENING.
THEY WILL BRIBE IT TO DEATH AND
JAM IT THROUGH.
>> Dagen: COME ON.
THEY REINTRODUCE THE SALT.
>> Lawrence: I AM SIDING WITH
THE PROGRESSIVES ON THIS.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU WHY.
THE PROGRESSIVES DIDN'T CHANGE.
THEY ARE IN LINE WITH THE NEW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY WERE PROMISED THINGS ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, EVEN THOUGH
JOE BIDEN SAID HE WAS A
MODERATE, BUT POLICIES HE'S
PUTTING OUT WERE CONSISTENT WITH
THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS.
YOU HAVE MANCHIN, A SQUISH WHEN
IT COMES TO THE DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THAT PROGRESSIVES SHOULD
HOLD THE LINE.
BY THE WAY, NANCY PELOSI AND THE
LEADERSHIP SHOULD STOP DOING
PRESS CONFERENCES.
THEY KEEP SAYING THAT THEY HAVE
REACHED AN AGREEMENT.
THEY HAVE NOT REACHED AN
AGREEMENT.
THEY HAVE LOST VOTER TURNOUT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
THE PROGRESSIVES, THEY DIDN'T
LOSE THIS ELECTION.
THE TURNOUT WAS SO LOW, THEY
DIDN'T DELIVER ON WHAT THEY SAID
THEY WERE GOING TO DELIVER FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND QUITE
FRANKLY I AGREE WITH HIM.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF YOU
TELL YOUR ELECTORATE THEY ARE
GOING TO DO SOMETHING AND YOU
DON'T DO IT, YOU SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Jessica: SINCE LAWRENCE IS
PLAYING AT PROGRESSIVE TODAY, I
GUESS I CAN HANG IN THE MODERATE
WING.
I THINK THEY SHOULD PASS
INFRASTRUCTURE AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE AND SHOULD HAVE DONE IT
SIX WEEKS AGO WHEN THEY GOT THE
GO-AHEAD FROM THE SENATE.
THAT'S SOMETHING, THEY HAD
SEVEN, EIGHT REPUBLICAN SENATORS
ON BOARD.
IT'S A WIN FOR EVERYBODY.
INFRASTRUCTURE ALWAYS WORKS THAT
WAY.
EVERYONE HAS SOMETHING TO GO
INTO THE MIDTERMS WITH.
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN PLUS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THIS GETS
PASSED.
PROBABLY NEXT WEEK.
THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS WANTS
THEM TO COME TOGETHER.
TO LAWRENCE'S POINT ABOUT OUR
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION, I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN A
PARTY IS TAKING TWO DIFFERENT
LESSONS FROM AN ELECTION OUT,
YOU'RE GOING TO END UP WITH A
LOT OF FISSURES IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH BECAUSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF MODERATE DEMOCRATS
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR MIDTERMS
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY SAW IN
VIRGINIA, THAT NEW JERSEY WAS
CLOSER THAN IT SHOULD'VE BEEN
EVEN THOUGH PHIL MURPHY PULLED
OFF AN INCREDIBLE FEAT.
NO DEMOCRAT HAS BEEN REELECTED
SINCE 1977 TO THE GOVERNORSHIP.
ALL OF THIS ALSO TAKES AWAY FROM
BEING ABLE TO TALK ABOUT VERY
REAL ACCOMPLISHMENTS, LIKE
TODAY'S JOBS REPORT.
531 JOBS ADDED IN AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER.
5 MILLION JOBS ADDED IN TOTAL,
AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON.
>> Dagen: 4.6 UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE.
ON THAT NOTE, BIDEN SAID WE NEED
THESE BILLS TO PUT THE PANDEMIC
BEHIND US.
THE PANDEMIC IS OVER.
THIS EVIDENCE ON THE ECONOMY.
WE ARE COMING OUT OF THIS, THE
ECONOMY IS GROWING.
PANDEMIC OVER.
ALSO BIDEN LAST WEEK WHEN HE WAS
CAMPAIGNING FOR
TERRY McAULIFFE, HE WAS ARMPIT
TO ARMPIT WITH PEOPLE IN A
LIBERAL MOSH PIT.
NO MASK ANYWHERE.
PANDEMIC IS OVER.
>> Pete: THAT'S A GARBAGE WAY
THEY ARE TEMPING TO SALAD.
THE BIGGER DYNAMIC IS WHAT
HAPPENED IN VIRGINIA AND
NEW JERSEY.
YOU MENTIONED THE CORN HUSKER
KICKBACK IN THE LOUISIANA
PURSES.
HOW MANY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
THAT WERE PART OF THOSE DEALS
ARE STILL MEMBERS OF CONGRESS?
IT IS GOD HEIMER AND THE OTHERS
IN THE MODERATE WING, THEY ARE
SAYING HOW ABOUT WE HOLD OUT 72
HOURS SO WE CAN READ THE 2,000
PAGE SOCIAL IS STILL THE DOESN'T
HAVE A CBO SCORE.
NANCY WANTS ONCE AGAIN TO PASS
THE BILL SO WE CAN FIND OUT
WHAT'S IN IT.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S IN IT.
WE WERE GOING TO GO BACK TO
NORMS IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, THEY HELD THE
VOTE OPEN LONGER THAN ANY OTHER
ROAD.
THERE IS NO REGULAR ORDER AT
ALL.
SHE IS JAMMING THIS THROUGH.
THEY SAY THAT IT'S GOING TO
REDUCE THE DEFICIT FOR
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
POINTING OUT IT'S A $4 TRILLION
BILL AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL, IF THERE WERE SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE IN IT.
MOST REPUBLICANS ARE NOT VOTING
FOR THAT ONE.
MOST REPUBLICANS ARE NOT GOING
TO VOTE FOR THAT BILL BECAUSE
THEY RECOGNIZE WHAT IT IS, A
PRECURSOR TO THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
>> Lawrence: NANCY PELOSI WITH
ALL THIS CHAOS HAPPENING.
THE PROGRESSIVES KICKED HER OUT
OF THEIR MEETING LAST WEEK.
>> Dagen: MEDICARE TRUST F